l'optimisme de donald trump se heurte à
la réalité du coronavirus c'est
désormais officiel le président
américain ne lèvera pas les mesures de
distanciation social avant pâques comme
il l'avait prévu pour la mi avril c'est
dorénavant le pic épidémique qui est à
l'ordre du jour je veux que le peuple
américain sache que vos efforts
désintéressé inspirant et courageux sauf
d'innombrables vies vous fait la
différence
la modélisation estime que le pic du
taux de mortalité devrait être atteint
dans les deux semaines
je le répète le pic le point culminant
du taux de mortalité n'oubliez pas il
est probable qu'il soit atteint dans
deux semaines hendrix rien ne serait
pire que de déclarer la victoire avant
que la victoire ne soit acquise
ce serait là notre plus grande perte le
milliardaire américain qui a ensuite
exhorté la population à être disciplinés
les deux prochaines semaines et pendant
cette période il est très important que
chacun suive rigoureusement les
directives recommandé par notre grand
vice président il y tient beaucoup
il y croit fermement mieux vous agirez
plus vite ce cauchemar prendra fin c'est
pourquoi nous allons prolonger nos
lignes directrices jusqu'au 30 avril
pour ralentir la propagation
l'immunologiste anthony fochi conseiller
du locataire de la maison blanche estime
lui que le virus pourrait tuer entre
cent mille dhs et 200 mille personnes
dans le pays selon les derniers chiffres
officiels environ 135 mille cas ont été
recensés dont plus de 2300 décès et 2600
personnes guéries pour venir à bout du
coït 19 donald trump oriente sa
stratégie sur les tests rapides
le déploiement des tests rapides va
considérablement accéléré notre capacité
à surveiller suivre contenir et
finalement vaincre le virus nous
vaincrons le virus il nous permettra
également de tester
yat mans les médecins les infirmières et
les autres travailleurs de la santé et
d'agir rapidement et énergiquement pour
arrêter la propagation du virus
si importante dans les installations
critiques tels que les hôpitaux et les
maisons de soins alors que le président
américain a renoncé à placer l'état de
new york en quarantaine plusieurs
initiatives voient le jour sur place ici
à central park
une ong installe un hôpital de campagne
qui pourraient être opérationnelles en
ce début de semaine